foreign
[Music]
okay
oh that was also in here 14. honeys
ummies I'm sorry I was like I'm sorry
oh that's a good answer
what
we take the easy way out
option two
we just
keep
what are you talking about it's over
she's pushing through right she's better
than me
that's a girl that's my girl storm it's
two minutes
two days
we don't give that up
I don't want to give that up
don't give up oh my God
oh my God they could just be a poetic
and [__] girls
what's option three
more babies at first I was very sad but
then seeing how storm pushed through
that
okay I just realized she says I'm sorry
when Ellie leaves a little I'm sorry pad
oh yeah that's a good call yeah she
doesn't want Ellie doesn't want to
conceive or uh uh Riley doesn't want to
conceive of Ellie hurting herself so
she'd rather just like let's just change
like let's not crazy change I changed my
emotions about it I'm happier now
welcome back to new rock stars The Last
of Us episode seven left behind is here
this is the break room Our Daily Show
that keeps you updated on all the dirty
news that you need to know and today
we're talking about uh Last of Us
episode seven so find your best friend
and break open the Halloween decorations
and just jump in you guys just jump in
I'm Jessica Clements and with me today
is Brandon Barrick I was really the most
afraid when they were dancing on top of
the glass cabinet kept showing the feet
I thought they were gonna crash through
and cut their legs or something no
they're like 80 pounds soaking wet and
Anna vanston if I was locked in a mall
Auntie Anne's wouldn't know what oh baby
yeah we're saying to your hands oh God
about the taco meat I was like bad right
I was like it's bad right at the mall
right no way it was all right oh yeah
because like they can extend it well 20
years I think it might get better right
that's right it's more dangerous for us
well uh before we jump into the episode
today we want to remind you there's
still time to head over to nerd Riot
dive shop and grab their newly released
shirt inspired by The Last of Us called
Lost in the darkness you could pick up
this awesome shirt at nerd riot.shop or
you will also find tons of other great
merch uh order this shirt now and get it
before the finale in just a couple of
weeks this Show's almost over can you
believe it I am so sad about it support
the channel and rock some great merch at
nerd riot.shop and also we got to keep
reminding you reminding you about this
awesome little jacket here this flint
and Tinder wax canvas trucker jacket
from huckberry oh
this is a flint and Tinder waxed canvas
Tucker jacket from huckberry and it's
the same jacket that Joe wears on the
Last of Us the costume designer uh chose
this jacket and he wears it in many
episodes It's flannel lined so it's warm
and comfy and that waxed linen develops
a cool patina over time so everyone's
jacket will wear a little differently
the more you use it I walk down the
street and everyone's like check out
that patina and it's been raining it's
been raining uh in this area and I've
stayed so dry well just this part of my
body uh this jacket has made in the USA
from really sturdy stuff and we'll be
there for you should you be attacked by
a fungus infected creature inside your
local Halloween costume store okay
that's my mom please put some respect on
it if Anna's mom attacks you in a
Halloween store you'll be safe click the
link in this video's description to buy
your own and help support our last of us
coverage here at new rockstars uh as we
get into this episode a quick reminder
that the first part of our discussion
today will be spoiler free we'll just
talk about what we've seen in the show
so far we recommend if you haven't
played the game games to avoid reading
the comments if you're in the comments
don't be a spoiler just just be kind
okay there are a few foreshadowing
moments in this episode for folks that
have played the game so we'll be leaving
those out of the episode recap and
covering them at the end of the show
we'll warn you before we get into
spoilers about the games the DLC the
downloadable content the comic books all
the other stuff there uh but for now
we're gonna stay uh spoiler free and
dive into this episode kick us off Jess
okay the episode opens in an abandoned
neighborhood as Ellie tries to dress
Joel's wound Joel tells Ellie to go back
to Tommy and Ellie appropriately tells
him to shut the [__] up that's my
version of how Ellie would say it I say
it from my chest Joel is losing a lot of
blood and she needs something to stitch
him up I mean I I will say I noticed
they show this like there's a clear
Trail of the sleeping bag sled and the
blood leading into the garage so Joel's
not wrong to be like get the [__] out of
here because there's like a trail
leading route to it yeah yeah and he
wants to keep her safe Hunters go here
go here we cut to LA and federal school
with a Walkman we couldn't get her a
portable CD player because that's too
expensive during a post-apocalypse I'm
going to run with one of those oh thank
you so much I was going to say you have
to keep replacing the CD I guess you
have to keep replacing the tape maybe it
was easier to find a tape everyone had a
CD player I don't know I don't know so I
feel like Ellie would be more into vinyl
yeah yeah yeah
she carries
it's like a giant that giant megaphone
that's attached to an old school one
okay so I love the detail of the
flashing fluorescent lights here no one
is making Replacements in the apocalypse
they refuse it's still old school
gymnasium yeah what's more important uh
in the apocalypse soap or fluorescent
light tubes so like we've got to keep
you awake somehow Ellie's listening to
Pearl Jam's all or none with lyrics
about hopelessness both reflecting
Ellie's feelings about Joel in the
future and her feelings now as a kid in
federal school with her best friend
assumed dead leagues also I love Pearl
Jam one of belly's classmates tonsor
with a you don't fight she fights well
Bethany is in the infirmary with 15
stitches yeah yeah she does she could
put up a little fight when she's ready
too it would have been even better if
she had a record player
bam that would kill her though murderer
Captain Quang seemingly the dean of
fedrus School let's Ellie off the hook
easy with a cool guy Dean speech about
the two pass uh her life could be too I
do like you know this is something Craig
Mason and Neil druck would have talked
about the show allows them to explore
both sides like we're not just with our
heroes we can see the other side and
this kind of shows that yes Federer
fascists [__] hanging people for
their crimes but this guy is like trying
to help this girl work in the system and
you know he he has an old picture of his
wife and child I assume they're probably
gone but I didn't think about them uh
and he's he's trying to be the good guy
and you know he's not just all evil all
the time right I liked the part where he
turned his chair around backwards
I was gonna say he didn't do that and I
wish he did he could have been a little
cooler also you you thought he was
telling the truth about what that about
her yeah I think he was not watching
people clean up poop because I thought
he was just like well I think he sees
that Ali's smart she's intelligent she
could be doing better than she is he had
a daughter before it's clear that he's
wants her to have the best life she can
and I guess I only had really bad
guidance counselors in high school that
were just like we just want you out of
here we need to get you gone I need to
jump back real quick the the keychain
that he puts down and
then I did see that prop pop print I
didn't even think about it very smart uh
we see Ellie's dorm where she's reading
volume one of no pun intended and an
issue of savage Starlight the comic book
of this world her dorm wall has
references to astronauts and dinosaurs
we know she already loves astronauts
Ellie's two passions on her bedside
table she has a cassette tape of aha's
Take On Me which comes around as a
non-diegetic music in the mall uh but
also we we do hear that song in The Last
of Us Part two of the game she's also
got a a poster for the movie Innerspace
which I think is very funny with Dennis
Quaid uh and Martin Short I don't know
if it has anything to do with this world
it's about shrinking in it's about
diseases inside the body what is
diagnetic means diegetic means the music
is in the scene so the characters can
hear it too oh okay uh if it's
non-diegetic the characters don't hear
it for the audience
um
Riley scares the [__] out of Ellie
sneaking into her dorm room and Ellie
reminds her that they're best friends I
do love this I thought you'd think I I
thought you would think it was funny who
would think that's funny to be fair
Ellie does so much [__] that it's like
yeah I guess I would have thought it was
funny but then it's also like girl
you've been gone for two weeks I know
right uh but remember these girls are
friends they're definitely friends
friends uh especially as Riley shows a
tremendous amount of straight restraint
turning her back to Ellie as she changes
we're in about 15 minutes she tell her
uh she'll tell her she's imagined her in
lingerie before spicy lots of sparks
flying here a lot of attention a lot of
tension uh these are young children I
shouldn't talk like that Riley tells
Ellie that she's been recruited by the
fireflies and convinces her to sneak out
to have quote the best night of her life
which shouldn't be hard to do in this
awful world uh but we'll see how the
night goes I'm sure it's gonna be great
she also says to trust her with her life
that she should trust her that's true
she does I mean I was panicking too and
she's like I got be up in a few hours
and we're gonna sneak out I I got that
Panic as a good boy who follows the
rules all the time of like I'm not gonna
get enough sleep I got school tomorrow I
can't even well this personally I can't
jump off a fence so like I'm so loud
when I walk that I was like yeah no I
just don't have faith in myself being
quiet sneaking around with the ultimate
sneaky person I'd be like no I'm gonna
make a commotion by accident
run into a wall commotion by accident
it's a good 80s band name the pair sneak
into an abandoned Apartment Complex and
come across a dead could have been Joel
what do you think that man got them
pills
okay I think that makes sense
it's gonna come across a dead could have
been Joel that licks the bag uh the bag
of pills and bottles of booze Ellie's
flashlight Putters out which is likely
not to the game mechanic where your
flashlight would frequently frequently
flicker until you shook it Ellie asked
to hold Riley's Gun which is so goddamn
Ellie of her and Riley tells Ellie how
she was recruited by Marlene they
parkour their way to the entrance of the
local mall and make their way inside
they were jumping on those roofs and I
was so nervous that Ellie was gonna hit
something I was like Ellie's gonna land
and then she's gonna have to help her up
but then people are gonna hear her and
run to the mall when they were doing the
roof jumping in my mind I'm like
Alleyways are whiter than that right
like I don't know how it is in Boston
maybe like a tiny Alleyways you know
it's an old city back in the day people
were tiny I think they were only three
feet tall uh in colonial times yeah uh
but them jumping the rooftops I was like
that is ballsy my sphere of heights
could never yeah but I mean These Girls
Aren't that scared even when they see
that dead body right they're not like
freaked out and Ellie is showing her
early uh psychotic behavior got right up
to it it did it gave me major The Vibes
where she cut over the thing right and
it was interesting how because I was
like immediately I was like oh they've
clearly seen a lot of dead bodies but
then Ellie's like have you ever seen a
dead body before and she's like duh my
parents uh very sad such a horrible way
but a few seconds later they're talking
about you know Federal hanging people so
it's like I think they've seen dead
bodies but they don't processing the
same way yeah I guess you're when you're
bred in the world of just like seeing
people get I mean early early day of
public executions and guilty and what
have you the people chanted for it right
but seeing someone accidentally die well
definitely death is such a big part of
their lives from when these girls were
both born they're born into a world of
death and destruction burning bodies in
the street and stuff people being hot
it's different yeah it's weird to be
like it's different when it's like uh a
murder versus right oh yes it's like
that's a man a man on his pill pill and
booze train yes either saying goodbye
either way so sorry Riley flips on the
power and Ellie loses her [__] over an
escalator cutest thing I've ever seen
they pass a poster for the movie Dawn of
the Wolf Part 2 which in the game is the
last movie Joel and Sarah saw together
yeah la checks a reflection in the glass
of the Victoria's Secret because she's
trying to impress her best friend just
friends uh and then they head to the
second Wonder of them all the
Merry-Go-Round the Merry-Go-Round plays
an instrumental of the cures just like
Heaven which was really sweet that being
diegetic they could hear that uh on the
thing because when the carousel broke
down the song stopped the band's called
The Cure yeah yeah
and the song is Just Like Heaven
oh no
uh
Riley mentions that other qzs have been
liberated liberated and are quote how
they used to be kind of a not we know
Kansas City just got liberated uh we
don't have any indication from the show
or games what those qzs might be but you
know it might be they're talking about
Kansas City but it ain't great there we
know that we know that the next wonder
of the mall is a time machine AKA a
photo booth everyone knows you're
supposed to make out in the photo booth
okay I thought this is when the kiss was
coming yeah but they're moving quick
they don't know what to do put me in a
choke hold I talked to John about it I
was like this is exactly the first kiss
I had with my best friend
no we didn't go in a photo booth it was
we were holding hands walking home and
then
one of us went back in the closet but it
it was the same situation of like you
just don't know and you're best friends
and you're young and you don't know if
they wanted it did seem like it was
going to happen then yeah right I
thought that would be the fourth photo
right yeah I I was very conflicted about
all the drinking that was happening they
were drinking a lot yeah because I was
watching that bottle knowing I was
just a drunken accident like I do
believe the feelings are genuine and
everything like that so but it unlocks
their inhibitions in a way right it lets
down those social guards in a 14 year
old
uh it's a Rogers arcade Roger is a
reference to a different naughty dog
video game Uncharted specifically Eddie
and Rika Raja Riley and Ellie play
Mortal Kombat 2. Ellie mentions this
game back in episode four and has a
poster of the game in her dorm room you
know she talked about how she knew that
that character could suck in a body and
spit out the bones uh and The Last of Us
video game they're playing a fictional
game called the turning which is a
similar fighting game one interesting
detail if you're a fan of the games
there is no reference to Mortal Kombat
in the original game but they did sneak
in a Mortal Kombat 2 poster into Ellie's
dorm room when they remade The Last of
Us Part One in 2022 since principal
photography for the Show wrapped before
the game was released there's a good
chance this was included as a little
Easter egg to the show if you've been
listening to the uh Show podcast that
HBO puts out with Craig Mason and Neil
Jackman Mason talks about like when he
was first working with drug went to put
the show together they haven't even
released part two yet and he got to see
like an early piece of the game wow so
they've been working on this show for a
long long time the camera dollies down a
hallway and we've passed some American
Girl dolls and a runner showing signs of
Life what's more scary the dolls or the
infected man I was looking for the doll
that had my name because they had oh
they have Jessica had the Sarah and I
was like where's Jessica but then I was
also like
this job has made me uh look into things
too much and I was like this the doll's
names have nothing to do with the show
my sister my sister had a Samantha
she was the worst
she's the most rich [__] she's terrible
I love her so she loves brunette and
played the violin that's all I remember
about Sarah she called her grand or
grandmary and that's all I need to know
to be like
even more Grandma I'm so tired of being
a little girl
more puppets
um Ellie lands a fatality fatality on
Riley and wants a kiss so bad but Riley
wants to move on a disappointed Ellie
tries to leave until Riley tells her she
has a gift for her and no it's not tacos
not tacos uh she'll land that fatality
later don't worry hey let me tell you
about it Ellie actually asked if it's a
water pistol which is a reference to a
mini game in the DLC that was cut from
the show and turns out
the gift the the surprise it's bombs uh
that Ryan has been building that and
volume two of will Livingston's no pun
intended by the way if you're looking
for an answer to what do you call an
alligator in a vest it's an investigator
an investigator I didn't even get to
guess do we have more puns to make that
pun book still uh we'll have to look for
the old words that might be around here
somewhere uh I do love not knowing what
a screenshot is oh yeah I forgot that
the screenshots exist in no 2003 no were
people screenshotting no they were no
they weren't that's wrong
whatever I noticed as a former Subway
Sandwich Artist I do believe that Subway
logo was a little too modern for 2003. I
need to do the research they could be
right but I feel like that design that
store design didn't get rolled out until
later in the mid-2000s unless we're
saying that Boston was a test market for
new style that's a production designer
breathe they had to decorate an entire
mall I'm always thinking do we think
that these brands that are shown all
decrepit in the post-apocalyptic world
have they paid for those spots or is
this repentance I mean I do feel like
Things Remembered was a little destroyed
uh there was an old Target ad an old
LensCrafter ad but that Subway still
looked pretty nice it was a little shiny
Subway was like lights were working
pretty well the bread is just a minute
they were like oh I think there's a a
runner but I also smell fresh bread ooh
Italian herbs and cheese oh Parmesan
oregano Brandon bread is not my way to
go and then oh that's true bad choice
you were the monsters all along oh boy
after discovering the bombs Ellie is
rightly pissed and Riley tells her she's
being shipped off to Atlanta tomorrow
this is a side question you think one of
those bombs we say it late is that a
bomb we saw go off in the first episode
that freed test you think it was one of
those bombs could be it could be could
be so yeah Ellie's mad about uh Riley
going off to Atlanta tomorrow because uh
what the heck what the heck lady you
just came back and now you're already
leaving Riley had asked Marlene if Ellie
could join and it's Marlene who said no
she did not want Ellie to go and we know
why because she's keeping tabs on her
which is possibly why Marlene knew who
Riley was in the first place because if
you think about it if if Marlene's
keeping eyes on Ellie she's probably
noticed that Ellie hangs out with Riley
a lot that's how she saw Riley sneaking
around maybe would she have purposefully
taken her away oh to keep Ali safe oh I
like that Ellie storms off and Riley
hits her with the Halloween decoration
making a screaming noise so you think
your friend's getting attacked and you
come back to save them from a quarter
step zombie that classic move it's funny
all this chick in the book I mean it got
me I heard the screaming I was like up
she's being attacked here here it comes
and it still got me so rude as hell
Jokes Aside it is really sweet that
Ellie was already making her way back to
Riley before the toy started screaming
because she knew this was not the way to
end things or honestly maybe she was
just going back for that punt book
because she had to make sure she get it
she likes the puns I feel it Riley Jacks
Ellie's Walkman is the Halloween store
stereo and the pair get down to Etta
James's cover of Sonny and shares I Got
You Babe with their game accurate
Halloween masks Ellie asked Riley not to
go and she says okay they share a kiss
and for a very very brief moment Ellie
has everything she has ever wanted until
the runner I mean that smile she gives
after Riley visits
I was screaming alone in my house uh
only because I yeah this is this part
Ellie is able to take down the runner
with her knife but not before both her
and Riley are bit and what a performance
by Bella Ramsey here going from
exhilaration to fear
desperately wiping off her arm ah I'd be
like no no no no and then like yeah yeah
we cut back to Joel just taking a nap in
the garage what a lazy [__] Ellie
finds some sewing thread to stitch Joel
back up oh boy we start the episode with
Ellie giving a girl an injury that needs
stitches and end her with her healing
Joel via stitches back in the mall Riley
tells Ellie they have two options the
easy way out or the poetic option they
lose their minds together Ellie asked
Riley for a third option but there isn't
one we cut away before we find out what
that could be the couple holds hands and
we match cut to Ellie holding onto
Joel's hand in the end of the episode
and him like squeezing her hand is the
cutest thing ever oh he loves her so
much okay so uh what an episode
incredible stuff but let's talk more
about this third option Ali mentions we
know obviously since Ellie's immune that
they do have they do have to take a
third option one where Ellie lives but
Riley does not we've speculated in the
past that the person Ellie might have
heard before is Riley though she does
kind of indicate she wouldn't like that
option but would Ellie even have a
choice here if like Riley starts to turn
she would also probably have to make a
move right yeah I mean there it really
boils down to there are two options at
that point too once Riley turns and that
is either run and escape and leave her
in the mall or kill her yeah or do does
Riley start to turn she locks her away
thinking like oh I'll turn soon because
obviously she gets separated enough from
Riley whether through blocking the path
or Riley being killed either by her or
some fireflies who show up uh she does
enough because if she was next to Riley
when the attorney's happening as as Tess
has pointed out she could still be
ripped apart right she could still be
brutally uh violently injured so
something must happen there uh that is
like a weird third option uh I'll also
ask you both like how do we think Ellie
gets from the mall to where she is with
Marlene how do we think that process
success went do you think she went back
do you think she didn't go back I don't
think Ellie leaves Riley at any point I
think Marlene finds Riley I think she
knows she's stationed up there and she
knows there's bombs there yeah that's
the shitty saying of it all is being
like yeah we're safe here and there's
one Runner
because it's like it's even
I mean maybe the runner never would have
woken up if it was still just her by
herself but it's like there's still one
Runner there so you guys didn't
completely check this area to make sure
it was clear and I wonder so sorry uh I
was just gonna say I was wondering you
mentioned the one Runner uh and the
timing of that I think it awoken awoke
when they were in the arcade right which
was pretty clean so I almost wonder if
the hive mine set it up was set off when
they were looking at that one guy who
was dead in the hallway that's what I
was thinking a little bit too because I
saw his I was looking at his like hair
on his chin and there was like stuff in
it yeah
that's why I was like I think he's
infected unless he like just vomited a
lot of whatever he ate last on himself
but I think he was a little infected and
I I would say too that the runner we see
the the growth looks pretty fresh like
we've seen in Boston how it can dry out
but it looked pretty vibrant it's not
like him coming back uh waking up I I he
might have been pretty recent to that
mall too because we have to assume that
with fire fights knew this was a place
they could store stuff I don't know they
probably wouldn't have stationed right
there if they thought yeah it was clear
yeah it wasn't clear
um yeah I guess I so it could have been
either like a high mind Roots kind of
thing I guess he could have just heard
them but it didn't seem like they were
making less noise they could have
stepped on a piece somewhere that they
just don't show on the camera
um but yeah I do think we know Riley's
supposed to ship out the next morning so
I assume Marlene would show up to this
place or someone from the fireflies
would show up in his place absolutely it
would probably be Marlene knowing that
she's kind of she seems like the Handler
for Riley for the most part so Marlene
shows up we know she cares about Ellie
whatever situation she walks into I'm
wondering how she just how they get
Ellie from the mall back to the
fireflies right without anyone seeing in
public you don't if they know Ellie has
been bit and they assume she's going to
turn any second so you're not you're not
gonna like grab her by the arm and walk
with her do you put a bag over it throw
around a truck or something they were
probably skeptical because immediately
if Riley changed and she didn't it's
like why didn't she change it quicker
than you but and if it was more than a
day for perhaps if it was more than that
they're probably like yeah this is weird
let's just take her with us just to make
sure well and that's that's totally
driven by Marlene yeah we know Marlene's
hiding it from most of the fireflies
only a small like her Lieutenant had no
idea what was going on with this girl uh
and we know Marlene is was friends with
Ellie's mother and wants to keep her
safe promise to keep her safe uh and the
fact that she doesn't turn is very
interesting probably to Marlene because
I would think the Instinct of any
firefighter who sees a bit person is
like just kill him well at least because
luckily since Marley knew her before
she's probably like this is a 14 year
old she's no fight I have no fight with
her like I can kill her easily if she
changes yeah so maybe that's why she was
like if you change I'll just shoot you
in the head like
I don't think Marlene was keeping the
immunity a secret from the other
fireflies because they were testing her
wow she was Keeping a Secret from most
of the fireflies remember that her
Lieutenant was like why do you have a
girl in a room why what are you doing
with her like she there were the people
who were testing her knew about the
situation and Marlene knows but like
she's keeping it a secret from most of
the fireflies because she knows the
importance of like what this could mean
uh one other thing I'd like to ask you
about is like what's the likelihood we
get more Riley uh either in a flashback
to earlier in their relationship or a
quick memory of Ellie having to maybe
kill Riley or even just the trauma of
watching her turn because in the game
there's not too much of a spoiler the
game never shows us the game basically
cuts when the show Cuts uh we never see
what happens to Riley exactly uh so do
we think it's possible we'll get more in
the show because as the creators have
said they want to have some surprises
for people who played the game what's
unlikely we got two more episodes you
think there will be more to this
flashback that Ellie just had
I hope it stays like this I hope it
personally you don't mind anymore I like
it being up in the air that here's two
options I'm never gonna give you three
and one of you is alive and one of you
is dead and we know they took whatever
whatever the third option is is what
what wound up so I like the idea of
leaving that in the air but if it had
that if it had to come back up I would
assume it'd be like in us a quick like
like jewel is like kill me or something
and she's like holding a gun and she
gets a flash of Riley she's like no I
don't want to oh yeah I I don't see they
it was contained so neatly that I don't
see them bringing it back like flashing
back it also felt like to add to that it
felt like it was more about their
relationship and like how much that can
uh mirror what she's going through with
Joel trying to save his life when she
couldn't save Riley's so I think more of
the message of the episode is like
here's Ellie's flashback here's Ellie
and this is why she feels this way about
a lot of people and that's it okay
that's what we're leaving it kind of
like Bill and Frank's episode yeah
they're dead in this room we're not
going to talk anything I would be very
inclined to side with that idea but I
think the fact that last episode we got
a little glimpse of Sarah again I'm
thinking we might see Sarah again and we
might see Riley again no I don't know
they could bring Riley back in infected
form
this goes back to what I said in the
first episode I want to see the
cordyceps making people play football
team versus quarter steps team playing
football the stands are full of infected
people going is it infected popcorn man
there's an infected announcer like I
don't know it's Tacos No it's tacos and
now it's tacos that's the easy thing it
doesn't cost a thing you just find a
couple
couple rap tag zombies on the street you
know what don't cost a thing love love
don't cost
uh well we got lots more to talk about
with this episode we'll get into some
spoilers but first it's time for the
gross out moment of the week brought to
you by quip and this week's moment was
pretty gross roll that tape oh awesome
oh this hurts so fast specifically fast
forward give him something to bite down
on
oh my gosh also don't rush no no reason
to rush how is she not a sew uh this
same thing
the same day I watched this I had just
sewn up a jacket a black jacket of mine
did that did the jacket scream in pain I
was like you know what her technique
isn't too bad
of course she knows how to sew there's
not clothing stores you gotta fix your
clothes all the time gross that was so
gross you know what else is gross bad
breath and tooth decay thankfully our
friends at quip have the perfect
survival kit to keep your oral gross out
moments in check uh I got some of the
supplies
Crips water flosser hits all the right
spots ah with gentle or deep clean
pressure at the touch of a button it's
cordless and rechargeable battery lasts
up to eight weeks with daily use no
bulking charging dock or Tangled cords
like that very easy to use also clip has
electric toothbrushes they have time
Sonic vibrations with 30 second pulses
to guide a decade dentist recommended
good two minute clean okay if you're
gonna survive the apocalypse you got to
have good teeth make sure you brush them
for at least two minutes each time and
quips gum starter kit comes with a slim
travel ready dispenser pack uh that has
10 pieces of gum at a time and fits just
about any purse or pocket for on the go
you just
oh look at that gum cute uh but yeah
this is great because she's keeping your
pockets on the go it's easy the quip oh
boy the quick apocalypse do we like the
sound of that no quip apocalypse I love
it apocalypse the oh shouldn't be there
that's what's throwing me off the
Apocalypse
has begun and quip wants to know who
your favorite Last of Us character is is
it Joel or is it Ellie just go to
getquip.com infected and place your vote
by using one of these promo codes either
Joel or Ellie Ellie or Joel jelly jelly
would be both of them you have to pick
one or the other you spell Ellie e l l i
e how do you spell Joel
j-o-e-l either code will automatically
get you 20 off an equip flosser quip
toothbrush or quips gum starter kit plus
if your favorite character ends up
getting the most votes Joel or Ellie
quip will send you a special power up to
help fight off those infected plaque
monsters coming for you in the arcades
and the Halloween stores of your life
this contest will last for only one week
so be sure to get your votes in before
midnight on March 8th the winner will be
announced on the final episode of The
Last of Us breakdown we do here on the
channel we will also cosplay is whoever
the winner is so if Joel wins we'll all
dress up as Joel and I'll look great uh
if Ellie wins will all dress up as Ellie
and I'll look great you'll wear that
jacket for the 18th time I'll let my
hair done and I'll be Ellie and you all
be very happy and I'll shave my eyebrow
uh also glad to hear this I want to know
more about the 7-Eleven incident that
damaged her eyebrow that's what I want
to learn so yeah go to getquip.com
infected and enter promo codes Joel or
Ellie not jelly very important very
important well let's talk game thing
okay so this one's the spoilers we're
gonna get into changes from the game
I'm gonna say it again uh this is for
those of you if you don't if you want to
play the game clean you don't want to
know anything that happens in the game
click away this is your warning we're
talking about the game just the stuff
the show is covered not the feature all
right so one of the big differences was
the federal school stuff we never saw
anything that happened at federal school
it was just little Whispers I mean we
did see her dorm when she came in right
but we the whole running around lapse of
the gym the beating up the girls no
Bethany no Bethany Bethany get out of
here
um also
what I said yeah get Bethany uh finding
the Dead Guy not a thing that's that
one's new didn't happen in the game
um but you know I'll always if we can
find a dead guy in the show I'll take it
I also argue the game has a thousand
more dead guys
that you made Dead Yourself yeah yeah
I'm sorry
um so all of Ellie looking for meds in
the mall in the game is cut out uh she
basically is going to look to help Joel
and find supplies and stuff like that
um this this episode they just kind of
contained it to one flashback whereas in
the game it sort of cuts back and forth
between helping Joel and uh
Riley remembering the past remembering
the past
um we also get a subplot told through
voice recordings and letters about a
military group crashing their helicopter
into the mall and one by one getting
infected and fighting over how to handle
the situation so a lot more of that in
the game there are so many little side
back stories that you get through
recordings letters and it had to really
pump up the DLC
uh so in the show when Ellie asked Riley
to prove she's a firefly she shows her
gun I was gonna say gum I was thinking
about quiet clip you're on my mind maybe
uh in the game she shows the Firefly
pendants that she has around her neck
which is one of the Collectibles from
the game so that's a new little thing
um there are also things that are cuts
that were in the DLC uh you mentioned
the water guns earlier they have a water
gun fight they throw bricks at some cars
there's like target practice who can hit
the cars more and also the Halloween
store they spend a lot more time in they
she like does a little magic eight ball
and asks a bunch of different questions
uh that the mass moments are kind of
prolonged although they didn't the mass
moments did not make me laugh in the
game like they did in this show
for some reason I love it that clown
very good it was like one of the best
wolf masks I've ever I've ever seen yeah
really really high quality good wolf
mask good wolf good wolf uh Riley is
also not making bombs for the fireflies
in the game that's not part of it she
just says that she has to leave and
that's sort of what gets Ellie uh worked
up
um and it's not mentioned that the
fireflies have our station there in the
game she just I think just kind of found
the mall and Michelle and Ellie uh we
also instead of that one infected being
the threat it's a whole horde that they
have to fight off
um which they successfully do until the
end until not so well until they don't
all right successful
um the game also has Riley and Ellie
kind of stand up and get up before uh
cutting to the credits
foreign
to wear I don't know probably Subway
um and in order to get some tacos and uh
in the show they they're still sitting
they're still just sitting there it is
interesting you know like Ellie having
to kill this infected uh you know it
does harken back to both when she sees
the dead guy in this episode and the
previous trapped infected you saw before
that she like slowly sliced and then
kind of like stabs in the eye and it
made me think that like Joel the person
who killed uh the person who managed
most to Joel was a human right it wasn't
the infected but to Ellie it's the
infected that killed the person she
loved the most so it's like they both
hate the other side more I think because
Ellie you know is raised by fedra and as
she deals with Riley she's kind of like
well fedra's doing some good stuff they
got the lights working again you know
trying to do all this you got the lights
on they have the lights on they're
hanging people what do you get the light
what are you gonna do real quick we'll
do our kill counts for this episode uh
Ali has one okay and the infected has
one we assume uh one it will happen she
will be amazing unless she's also immune
somewhere else
what a Twist what a Twist they've said
that some things have changed yeah if
the last episode we get a split cut to
like her in Atlanta a lot
that would be crazy that would be crazy
uh all right so as we wrap up this break
uh this episode let's talk about
spoilers all spoilers we can talk about
uh future game we could talk about other
comic book stuff that we know uh so
let's get into it right we had uh this
little joke what did the frustrated
cannibal do he threw up his hands uh
that could be a reference to the
cannibals that that are gonna come are
coming in the show they're gonna throw
up a hand before we just need them
uh we know there are cannibals in the
game that we're getting close to the
point where they would show up there's
they've been kind of referenced uh it's
next time throughout the show next time
it'll be the last episode it has to be
the next episode we also in this episode
we had aha's Take On Me uh Ellie will
play the song for uh Dina in Last of Us
Part Two so we assume we'll probably see
that again and another spoiler we we
think will be happening in the next
couple episodes we expected to see
Ashley Johnson uh the actress who voices
Ellie in the game Cameo here is Ellie's
mom uh but that didn't happen she was
listed on imgb to be in this episode
that of course didn't happen and IMDb is
not always right until something comes
out uh do you think that scene got cut
entirely or we see that somewhere in the
last couple of episodes we gotta see it
I think we're going to see Ashley
Johnson they love giving the voice
actors yeah a little stage time so we're
gonna see her um I think it's gonna be
the last episode I think it's gonna be
when they're in the hospital because in
the game in the hospital she finds all
the voice recordings of Marlene and
talking about her mom I think it's gonna
be we're gonna get flashback next to
Marlene and her mom and we and something
that you know maybe they're not able to
do in the game when Ali is put under an
aesthetic in the last episode she could
have like Visions about this I thought
we might see it because it was
interesting having Riley her kind of
mentioning that like she had a family
before and she remembers what that's
like and she wants to get back to that
and almost not really throwing it in
Ellie's face but as a juxtaposition to
Ali's attitude being like you don't know
what family is you know you've never
kind of known this like warm family and
that's what Drew Riley to the fireplace
is she wanted to have that feeling again
that she belonged somewhere because
she's getting literally the [__] end of
the Stick of fedra like her job was
going to be watching other people clean
up [__] that's why I didn't believe that
when he was like trying to clean the
[__] or you can tell people to cry but
it's also implied that Riley is like
worse yeah she's the the tough kid she's
beating people up she's sneaking out all
the time yeah Ellie's following along
with her but Ellie I think Captain Quan
thinks I can still change I could still
reach this kid I can change her I can
turn my chair around say hey you don't
gotta I know what it's like being a kid
when I was a kid
and they had Italian bmts and it was
delicious somebody's getting a lot of
air time
I'm such an idiot said Subway and I was
like yeah underground trains yeah of
course they had underground trains uh
yeah I I do agree though I think we'll
definitely see uh Ashley Johnson on the
show I'm wondering if they'll have uh I
wanted to have like a bigger camera I
understand playing Ellie's Mom right
complete sense but I'm just like she's
so good as Ellie yeah have her be in
there like two episodes yeah it's
something that hasn't been mentioned in
the show yet is that the comic book that
they released American Dreams uh for the
last of us uh revealed that the knife
that Ellie has originally belonged to
her mother uh and Marlene kind of like
referenced didn't reference didn't tell
Ali that in the first episode but
definitely pointed out the knife she's
obviously very protective of the knife
doesn't want you don't want to take it
does anyone take it it's her mom's knife
right right so like they haven't like
put that out in the show yet but I bet
that'll come up soon yeah you know I
assume Marlene's gonna show up uh in
Utah we'll see her again the timeline
would she remember her mom really well I
know that sounds weird but she doesn't
remember Marlene Marlene was the one who
put her in the fender Camp I don't I
don't think she remembers her mom at all
yeah so yeah I mean that's a good point
if she has the flashlight that's
actually a great point it might just be
this flashback for the audience yeah I
was like I think it'll be a flashback
for us or if like Marlene's talking
about her mother to Ellie you know we
see it from Marlene's perspective I
don't know uh it'll be interesting to
see how they they tie that all in
Marlene's literally gonna be in the
first episode in the last episode that's
wild nice work yeah that's what I'm like
damn that's wild as you might show up in
the very last second the second to last
episode very end maybe but these last
two episodes were are like our least
deadly episodes you know what I mean
like only one death here one death there
they're getting us ready for the
cannibals I know and that that's what
makes me worried like two and I say
light episodes they're still emotionally
heavy but like not as like awful as some
of the stuff we've seen already on the
show and we know that the next two
episodes are going to be intense and I
am worried about it look excited I saw
cocaine embarrassed I saw
they're out
Joel would love the cocaine bear they'd
find little baggies
bags okay you guys don't need some he
hasn't had Hydro in weeks months
he's like listen he was like did you
find a new painkillers up there
Joel is the cocaine
okay okay that is it for this episode of
the break room we'll be back next week
to discuss episode eight but we also do
the show every day live at 3 P.M talking
about all the new news that you need to
know and that you love and next week
we're actually going to be doing
yeah this coming Wednesday you'll see
Wikileaks is back uh it'll be our after
show for the Mandalorian yes so you got
two you get us and you get Wookie leaks
your little Wookie freaks follow me at
Lulu underscore Clemens fall brand net
green and Barrick follow Anna it's Anna
vanston subscribe to the break room
wherever you get your podcast and we'll
see you Tuesday thanks for watching
Halloween stores
foreign
[Music]